I take a lot of inspiration and look to
you guys because news is still in that
category like I was in it's funny
because I was in the Same Old Situation
like I was White House correspondent I
was in the Press briefing room I had two
options I was like I could stay classic
I Was Made man like going on Fox News
doing my hits I was like in the system
invited to all the parties but I was
like I [__] hate this yeah and I grew
up with Rogan and then that was what I
took inspiration like and I met Crystal
and it actually clicked and I was like
Hey like we could do something different
dude how many people told me not to take
the job how many people told me not to
start the show yeah you're a [__]
idiot what are you doing yeah you're not
gonna go on Fox anymore yeah you're
gonna give up all this yeah like how can
now they're like hey can I come on the
show oh that's interesting your Pock
what's the podcast ranked at can I I
just wrote a book my assistant I'm like
I don't care dude it's not like that
anymore yeah it's just like you said it
was uh cable by definition if you're on
CNN you're not on MSNBC yeah if you're
on MSNBC if you're not but with us we're
like oh you're on
rival whatever come on let's get it
going and then more people will watch us
and I always say I say subscribe to
their sub stack people are like why are
you doing that because you want to
promote your own thing I'm like no dude
put them on people want us to promote
better people bro you know what it is
yeah have you ever gone over to uh
Little India in New York like Sixth
Street there's two that's right Curry
Hills Curry Hill and then there's one
outside but there's both spiders right
um
perfect example it's like you would
think that by having multiple Indian
restaurants on the same street yes they
can't hurt each other no the opposite it
makes people go that's the place for
Indian food I want to try all of them I
want to make sure this food is good
exactly you get and if the places are
cool with one another they get to
exchange information they're like yo
these white people do not [__] with
dolls get the booty bread
so it's like like I don't know for me
seeing it from that perspective that's a
smart point I like that which is like
this is the district this is the
ecosystem and I think it's fun I mean
look I wish we could still change it I
think there's a lot more to do in a lot
of ways news is like the most lagging
part like you know the comedy internet
came for comedy when like 15 years ago
like it's just now happening in news
yeah like The Joe Rogan podcast came out
in 200 [__] nine yeah news is just
now starting it's one of those where
like we're so far behind the times but I
do think it's a good thing because they
are so propped up and like and and it's
it's like you said they're all the
questions what you guys are doing that
are like young and hungry and you would
like to promote them who else should do
I mean like Crystal's fiance Kyle Kyle
Kolinski he's actually one of the ogs
that's on there I know I mean a lot of
them uh there's what Russell Brand is
doing stuff like this now Glenn
Greenwald actually has that new show
yeah um Matt Ty EB is doing it for print
journalism yeah all of these guys are
David Sirota actually got lever news um
on the right I mean or even I mean Tim
pools I mean look undeniable his show is
massive like this is my thing like put
the value judgment aside I want more
people to watch sort things like that
because we have time like you and I are
sitting here and talking about the
single male crisis like we're [__]
around making jokes like all that stuff
but this is serious [__] like there's
actually
Fox yeah one time they were like Hey
we're going to talk about American
nationalism you have three minutes and
there's three people on the panel you
get your one time like you can't do
anything new ones you talk like a fake
you're like yeah that's right and one of
the reasons why is because of this one
particular statistic and I'll see you
later yeah what am I doing here yeah not
and I hated that but everybody is so
comfortable with that system that they
they like it right because that's where
the paychecks come from they're so used
to talking [__] going to the same
restaurants going to the same parties
and I was like hey this is all [__]
like golden handcuffs man you know it's
funny I remember in the Press briefing
room one of the funniest things is is
that every TV correspondent asks the
same question you know why because they
all need videotape of them on their own
network asking that question so during
the Trump okay so there's CNN Fox MSNBC
ABC all of them every single one of them
asked same version of the same question
in the Press briefing room at the
conference even though it's already been
answered even though it's already
answered you know why because they need
video of them on their Network what does
the president do when he gets asked the
same question he loves it because he
gets the answer also they get yeah
the same question yeah he's like I've
been 30 minutes with the Press what are
you talking about I'm free and
transparent and open so he'll say the
exact same thing over and over again
[__] this is
a slight tweak but it's like come on man
it's like during the like when Sarah
Sanders that was the time that I was
there she would be like all right uh
first question Mueller second question
Mueller third question Mueller finished
because Jim Acosta has to be on CNN
sparring with Sarah Sanders and then
Peter Alexander and NBC he needs to be
on NBC as far as Sarah Sanders and then
ABC needs to spark so it's the same
shackle theater and I was like hey what
about the other stuff that people care
about no what's going on with Trump that
the government are we going to war I
remember everybody in the Press
ridiculed me for saying do you think Kim
Jong-un is serious about peace talks
they're like why didn't you ask about
Mueller they [__] had one of the most
important major press for like foreign
policy moves of all time whenever Trump
met with Kim Jong-un yeah and we all
recognize that such but at that time I
don't even remember what the [__] was
going on some Jeff sessions [__] or
whatever and they were like they're like
whoa you didn't ask about Jeff sessions
I was like I don't know I just think
nuclear war is more important
there was one you've already just
touched on what was the most
disappointing thing peeking behind the
curtain that yeah which was I mean look
man I always loved politics I was the
political kid you know in school like
Iraq war is why I got into it and I get
to the Press Corps top of the most
Cutthroat of the Cutthroat [__]
make it into the Press briefing room and
I was like this is it though yeah I was
like this they stopped being cut through
it and it's hard to get here I was like
and that oh and wait so you know one of
the best pieces of advice I got was if
you want to be like the way that you
know you're in a good career is look at
the guy who's 10 years ahead of you and
I'm looking at these 65 year old
[__] doing the same [__] yeah
where and I was like oh my God I was
like I gotta get out of here okay I'm in
a prison all right guys we're gonna take
a break for a second because y'all need
some tickets man y'all gonna need
tickets to sold out events and where are
you gonna go get them you're gonna use
some untrusted website probably gonna
rip you off or you're gonna go with the
goats seat geek seat geek has got your
back with over 28 million downloads seat
geek is the number one rated ticketing
app there are more than 70 000 events
every single day on seeking including
concerts Sports festivals comedy shows
and more I'm telling you
music you want to go to a show
do you want to see Ed Sheeran
when I saw Ed Sheeran iucci to get the
tickets then I ran it back one more time
that's what I can do why are you going
to use Sea kick well because they
actually look out for you
they are going to put a nice little
Green Dot on the good deals Red Dot on
the bad deals think about that they're
letting you know if you can get a better
deal out there they have your back they
put all the tickets across the web in
one place so they know if the deal is
good or not and every ticket is backed
by their buyer guarantee and SeatGeek is
the only site that lets you return your
tickets ahead of the event with swaps so
if you use
our code flagrant you're gonna get
twenty dollars off at Sea geek what does
that mean that means that your ticket
just got better
that means that tickets just got closer
you just got closer to action all you
have to do is use that app and make sure
you use the code flagrant you're getting
20 off at seek geek make sure you use it
support this show and enjoy whatever
you're going to see let's get back to
the show peace all right guys listen
we're back and we've made a change we've
swapped Indians
Akash in the [__] pilot see
here once again and uh we gotta talk
about a little bit of this March Madness
okay y'all place your bets The Underdogs
are gonna win listen as simple as that
we told you it's all underdogs basically
San Diego State who the [__] are they
nobody's FM party school in the same
party I imagine not a good basketball
school FAU you ever even heard of them
wait a minute you know who went to San
Diego State who
Kawhi Leonard oh that's right board man
gets paid yeah yes yeah that's it that's
all they've ever done now they're the
final four let's go Miami party school
great at football historically bro never
good at basketball Princeton Princeton
damn near made it they made it to the
Sweet 16 I think they got beaten by
Creighton but uh Creighton made it to
you later this is crazy this is the
tournament you got to make your bets bet
on The Underdogs get some money yeah I
mean now it's so hard to tell I mean
I've been so tapped out from college
basketball to be honest with you me too
but that's why it don't matter bro
no I'm telling you it don't matter just
bet underdogs if you watch college
basketball all year the number one
overall loss to Arkansas yeah I think
every once he got eliminated dumb early
there's no one seeds left the highest
seed left is four you don't have to
watch just bet
just back
yes that's a good answer bet online.ag
you don't have to watch Tibet no you're
not watching exactly what I did yeah
hey yo and it was it was just as fun it
really is you could make an argument
it's more fun it's more fun and you're
not emotionally invested you're just
saying if you win or lose that's it and
you're betting on dogs and dogs are
winning who we bet and who we betting
with sound beta Lois bet FAU why not
highest odds
uh that's a good ass Point all right so
then we're going with FAU yeah and then
we're going with I guess Miami yeah
let's just bet Miami why the [__] not
all right shout out Florida all Florida
finals yeah we love it yeah where you
betting better online.ag music [__]
matching 50 of the initial deposit bonus
up to a thousand bucks
we back in it
let's swap Indians I have a I have a
question for you now that you control
completely what stories you talk about
whatever you do whatever you're
interested well me and Crystal but yes
yes yes you guys are in control there's
no interior